But it's important that we call out bad bad things. No, it's
not. Oh,
our eyes having a hard time pulling the broom out for this one.
That's not great, man. That is not good.
He said crust is critical.
>> NO. NO. [screaming] BAD. YOU STEP DOWN.
You step down, random podcast dude. You.
>> I want to start with the 2024 autopsy, which you call
an after-action review. On this show in August, you told me this
about releasing the review, quote, we have to do it to give people
who invested so much time, energy, and money a sense of what
happened and why we
Especially why we lost. So, what changed between August and December?
I understand there are lessons, but those are not the full report.
Why not release the full report? What's in the report that you
wouldn't want to publicize? >> Yeah, there's no smoking
gun in the report, and I know that's that's what everyone's so
eager to learn the smoking gun. Guess what, John? >> there's
no smoking gun, why wouldn't you just release it then? >> Because
we want to keep the focus on the lessons. At long last, the 2024
DNC autopsy report has been released, and >> Wow. it is
kind of a disaster. As we had discussed on this show, it turns
out that Paul Rivera, the person tapped by DNC chair Ken Martin
to produce this report, just kind of hit the bed. >> Ken
Martin gets credit, I think, for doing that. Like, it is belated,
but he put it out, he apologized, so that is good. On the other
hand, the more I like read his statement and read his Substack
and then looked at the report, like, he lied. He promised a report,
put his incompetent friend in charge of it. The incompetent friend
created an incoherent product. Then Ken announced that they weren't
going to release the report for reasons that had nothing to do
with the truth about why they weren't releasing it. Then, when
anyone asked about it, including me, he decided to not just lie,
but gaslight people into being like you're the problem. Why don't
you want to win? Why are you looking in the past? And then there's
like an internal revolt at the DNC and among donors and DNC members.
And so then they release this. Oh my god, Ira, talking about
the DNC. So, by the way, spoiler alert, Ken Martin stepping down
from the DNC? Oh, no, he's just about to step down or he they're
they're calling for him to step down. Okay, okay, okay. They're
People are like supporting him. It's like, yeah, they he completely
[__] up. It's all It's all complete
Why? Basically, the DNC is not taking care of its donors. The
The job of the DNC chair is to take care of the donors to party.
That's the job of the DNC chair, okay? At long last, the 2024
DNC autopsy report has been released and it is Is it kind of
a disaster? I These guys are going to find any way to attack
it. You know, what a what a real These guys are a piece of work,
man. I What side are you on? Right? Like just take a step back
for a
Does Ira I know? I Ira I should know.
What What heck inside are you on, man? Just take a step back
and really look at yourself and your party. Oh, come on, man.
Come on, man. What side are you on, man? Holy sh They They scream
about Ken Martin not releasing it forever. Then he releases it
and they still call it a disaster. Like this stuff
Dude, Ira I should know. Ira I should know this that these guys
are like party insiders. That they know a bunch of people. That
they know donors. That the reason they're causing a stink about
this is cuz they've heard this was bungled horribly and they
need to get the party back on track.
That's why they're making a stink about it. The donors want a
stink made about
Yes, the donors want people held accountable for how sh this
is. That stuff adds up, man. It starts to make people hate on
the Democrats and the left. And do you want the Democrats to
win or are you okay with them losing? You know, people say all
>> I just don't Guys, if you criticize Democrat Party,
you want them to lose. They You just want them to lose, man.
Don't Don't make it better. >> don't be a shill, dude.
Come on, we need to be able to criticize our side. She Yes, but
you need to couch it with compliments and say what's going well
and talk about why you still support the What's going well? What's
going well? >> Because obviously these chuckle do and yet
they act like they hate the party every time they get on camera
about
Obnoxious. It's fine to be critical, but how You got to also
The only thing going well is that you may have you may have the
least popular president ever in American history, like driving
your country into the dirt right now. That's the only thing that's
going well. Also say why you support and why it's important you
continue to support the
I I can't stand this
this this
just this strange mentality on the left that we're helping by
criticizing
and never offering anything good ever.
Ever. It's just constant tears and criticism and they think they're
helping for some reason. It's It's the saddest, stupidest loser
mentality ever.
This was a complete screw up. He originally said he would release
it, then he didn't, now he's releasing it. So what? He said if
he would never do anything that he thought would be would not
help. And he didn't think releasing the report would help. And
now he decided to release it. And he said "Sorry, I should have
done it. So, what's the big deal?" I I
>> Did he I Dude, I don't even know if he said that. I
don't even know I actually don't know if that's something he
said. I maybe should have watched it first. But it's like, this
guy really [__] up. SO WHAT? BY THE WAY, I don't
even think they're that mad about the report itself. It's more
of like what all of this means. It's that Ken Martin is not getting
money into the party. The The party or Lots of the big donors
wanted to see this report to see what the [__] went
wrong. So they could know how much to trust the Democratic Party
moving forward. The Releasing the report is step one. I I'm going
to tell you, it looks real bad when you release the report and
the report is basically like, "Yeah, we just didn't really, you
know, we just wanted to do this for free. We let We handed it
off to somebody else who's going to do They totally [__]
it up. I don't see why Why are people not celebrating him for
changing course and releasing it? Instead, they still attack
him. It's still not good enough, right? Like, that's insane to
me, dude. Um I think you're not releasing this because you guys
[__] it up and you guys are incompetent and I want
I want heads to roll for this. Okay, fine, I'll release it then.
Oh, so you were incompetent. Okay, I want heads to roll for this.
I I WAS LIKE, "COME ON, MAN. NOTHING'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR YOU GUYS.
COME ON. ISN'T IT GOOD? I THOUGHT HE CHANGED HIS MIND. He's releasing
IT. WHAT WHAT DO YOU WANT?" Uh the people to have done a good
job in the first place.
Like, literally, the reason it wasn't being released is because
they didn't want to be held accountable for the results. Now
it's being released and you want to hold them accountable for
the results and Technically, I think Ken Martin wasn't the person
who ordered it made, so perfect metaphor for an institutional
Democratic Party that seems unwilling to even face the moment.
Disclaimer, this document reflects the views of the author, not
the DNC. The DNC was not provided with the underlying sourcing,
interviews, or supporting data for many of the assertions contained
herein and therefore cannot independently verify the claims presented.
Conclusion,
this section is is provided by the
>> It what? Are you telling me they had a page that says
conclusion?
And then it's just empty? That's not That's not true.
There's no possible way.
There's no possible way they've got a conclusion and then it's
just empty.
Yeah, okay.
Surely this can't be the document that has the lessons of actually
everybody loves billionaires, man. Everybody loves Don't talk
about billionaires. Everybody loves billionaires. It couldn't
be that, right? With no data, with no polling. They just went
everybody loves billionaires actually. No way. Not possible.
People think the report was heavily AI generated. Oh boy. Oh
boy.
Greetings, Montreal.
I'm more mad that this report was so bad Okay, but do you understand
my frustration that people are just dogpiling on Ken Martin and
the DNC? And how does that help us in any way? It just makes
the left look bad. And you go, "Well, what But it's important
that we call out bad bad things." No, it's not. Do you think
you need to tell your partner every time they cook dinner that
it's not good? Or if they do something bad, you need to tell
them about it every time? You better You If you want to be happy,
you better couch that with some compliments, too. You know what
I mean? You You better say something nice if you want to go there.
Yeah, guys, if you just expect us to see our faults and get better
acknowledge our faults and get better, you're wrong. I need some
I need some sugar to make the medicine go down, okay? Give me
the sugar or I won't take the medicine. Go try that in anything
else in life.
criticize nonstop and then wonder why people don't vote for your
party. Why is nobody voting for the Democrats? I don't know,
cuz you [__] on them for two straight years. What
do you mean? Well, they were making mistakes and I felt I needed
to call it out. Well, what did what did that accomplish? All
you got is people angry at the Democrats. Well, they need to
do better, dude. They need to win me over. They need to do so
much.
Why is Ira's entire job to argue that politicians shouldn't politic?
COME ON. WHY DO YOU GUYS WANT ME TO DO WORK? WHY YOU GUYS WANT
DEMOCRATS TO DO WORK, MAN? COME ON, MAN. That seems really messed
up. All right, come on, man. You want me to do work and stuff,
man? Come on, man. I and and I demand perfection. I don't see
any positive things, even though I haven't looked and I don't
even bother trying.
It's crazy, man. I'm so tired of this
I'm so tired of it. This is not good enough at all. I feel absolutely
defrauded by these political entities and feel like I have suffered
serious damage. Please be sure to clip this so we can use it
when we submit our claims to the anti-weaponization free payouts
fund. Thanks. They're mad because it didn't mention Israel
Gaza, but they can't say that so they act like their criticism
is something else.
That person
Destiny watching Julian. No actual engagement with reality or
politics at all. Just Just Hassan is bad, Israel's good, Palestine
is bad, Palestine supporters are bad. No engagement with the
real world. This was never, at least for Pod Save, literally
never about Palestine. Ever. Ever. Ever. If you think that, you
have a
feeding you your political thoughts. Absolute facts, Nico. I
agree and I called it a mile away. I said, "When the report comes
out, and it inevitably will, it's not going to mention Gaza and
in the way these guys want it to, and they'll move the goalposts
and be mad about something else.
Gappy, thank you for the resub, bro. Appreciate that, man.
As we had discussed on the show, it turns out that Paul Rivera,
the person tapped by the DNC, by DNC chair Ken Martin, to produce
this report, just kind of [__] the bed, and turned
in >> He's already been surpassed by AI. Yes, he turned
in this incomplete analysis. It's riddled with errors. It's not
backed by source materials. It's seemingly So then wasn't it
smart for Ken Martin not to release it if it's riddled with errors
and it's not good and it was just a bad report? Why bother? He
He put out the lessons learned. So maybe he was right to not
put this out. Well, I I think probably what they should have
been doing, in my opinion at least, was actually having some
oversight on it, right? Not just farming it out to a donor, which
is apparently what happened. >> the centerpiece of his
campaign for DNC chair, then handed it to a buddy working part-time
who never even interviewed Harris or Waltz. The DNC is now disowning
their own report. Incredible.
>> Well, look, it it sounds like some mistakes were made,
which happen.
Sorry, sorry.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Destiny, look this. Turns out the report the our reporting was
correct.
Shout out @mattberg. This is exactly why it didn't matter if
it was released. Nothing short of Israel-Palestine was the sole
reason Kamala lost would have satisfied the people most obsessed
with this report.
Okay, you're responding to Jon Favreau. He doesn't care about
Israel-Palestine.
He doesn't care. He never cared.
This dude This guy's become the least
America's least informed political commentator. He actually doesn't
follow politics. He doesn't know anything. He is a total [__]
Very sad to watch. You know what I mean? I'll [__]
talk IRI sometimes, but at least IRI pays attention, okay? I'm
not going to be I'm not going to say IRI doesn't actually watch
politics or follow it at all. I don't
Destiny just seems totally detached from reality when I watch
him. It's crazy. And yes, he did campaign on releasing the report.
And then I'm a giving him the benefit of the doubt that the report
sucked and was useless and would just cause more problems and
he made an executive decision not to release it. He now admits
that was a mistake and he should have released the report. So,
I don't
Dude. Uh-huh. >> know what What what are you defending?
It's like a level of being a sycophant
like Trumpers do. Like this is how you end up looking the other
way as kids are getting abused. It's the same kind of process,
the same kind of operation that happens. Right? You basically
are deciding that it's better for your political party, your
political goals, to never criticize your own ever. And that extends
to everything. else to say? Like I want blue maga, but blue maga
doesn't work. Red maga like maga in the conservative party works.
Blue maga doesn't work at all. Blue maga is like inherently >> Like
he's our leader, he's not going anywhere. He was elected to be
the leader, he deserves a chance, and he's admitting to making
a mistake, you know? He said he should have released it. I I
don't think it's the end of the world.
What are we going to do? Just hold it against him for the rest
of uh the election cycle? I mean, Well, the guy [__]
up on his only campaign promise and he's totally failing to raise
money for donors and you guys have your war chest historically
depleted going into the midterms. Isn't that a problem? Aren't
all of those things problems? He's like [__] up every
major responsibility he has.
Right? Like what WHAT HAS KEN MARTIN DONE WELL?
WHAT IS HE DOING WELL ON?
I don't get it. What's what's the alternative? He's the leader.
Also said they didn't pay the guy for it yet we pay for. Well,
I I just because they didn't pay somebody for it doesn't mean
they weren't qualified to do it, and they weren't
an expert and knew what they were doing,
I I just challenge people to support our
People make mistakes. People misstep, but we on the left
lord it over them, and then we refuse to support our leaders.
He won the DNC chair. He deserves a chance to lead the party,
and if he makes a mistake, it's okay to call him out, but the
same people who call him out for making mistakes never praise
anything good that he does, and I think that's wrong. I don't
think that's how you you
get people to support the cause. I think
anytime you're criticizing, you should also be um pointing out
positive things. If it's something you care about, otherwise,
what do you Why do you care about it?
He underestimated how weird and conspiratorial people like Pod
Save America would be about it. I agree.
I absolutely agree.
He turned to
I Is it conspiratorial?
Hold on. Is it conspiratorial for people to expect the Epstein
files when Donald Trump campaigns on that? What do you think,
Ira? Do you think that's conspiratorial for them to say, "Well,
you campaigned on releasing the Epstein files. You said you were
going to do it." Is that conspiratorial to expect it?
I feel like that's the only campaign promise Ken Martin made
was, "I'm going to release that report. It's really
It's uh Holding politicians to their promises is a conspiratorial
belief now. Self-inflicted wound in a month's time traction of
time that can't afford it. I agree. He made a mistake, but it
did not impact the results of elections, and we won with that
going on, so maybe he needs to make Well, did Ira even listen
to what the original interview was about?
Does he know why they wanted it released? Does he you why they
like Tommy Vietor and Jon Favreau want this taken care of. Does
he have any idea?
It is that major party donors are not donating. The war [clears throat]
chest going into the midterms is insanely depleted. In a way
like never has been in previous midterms.
That's the problem.
You don't have a war chest going into What was it? The final
like 6 weeks before the election when you spend the most? You've
got no positive cash right now. You you are literally in debt.
Now you can carry some of that debt and maybe that's not such
a big deal.
But you're not holding money.
You don't got You You ain't got a war chest, man. That's a huge
deal. That's why they want it taken care of. That's why they
want it out in the open so that these donors can get confidence
back. Now I'm going to say probably the donors aren't getting
confidence back based on this report. This report looks like
every one of their biggest fears come true and you might need
a leadership change. That might just be required.
Anyway, we keep going. these mistakes in order for us to win.
I have no idea, but whatever he's doing is working. And so for
me, this is a nothingburger because if we were still failing
and we were not taking advantage of the situation and doing well,
then I think the criticism would be really valid in saying, "Hey
man, this is this is just another sign of this guy
making mistakes and not doing a good job and it's time for someone
else to take over." But the thing is we're doing about as good
as we possibly could do even with this happening. So I It's hard
for me to complain about anything.
You know, it's like
I gave an example of people who lose weight by eating Cheerios
or eating
Lucky Charms in the morning. You can do that. If you can break
down your macros and your calories and you can fit a bowl of
Lucky Charms into your diet, you can still lose weight.
You can lose weight, but you'd have to make some sacrifices in
other areas cuz you're probably going to get like 50% of your
sugar.
This is like
somehow you got like a blessing like a like a MMO blessing that
gives you like minus 1,000 calories in a day. You're like, "You
know what? I'm going to live my life as if this minus 100,000
calories is going to be there the whole
Minus 1,000 calories is like Maga being the most cataclysmic
event happened to your country ever.
Right? Like you are winning. You are winning the diet metaphor
by doing nothing. You can eat like total [__] and
you win anyway, right? But you're not building up habits for
a winning party long-term. In fact, you're yourself over
But the analogy works. You're just not actually executing the
analogy correctly. You are destroying your habits. You're destroying
the way your party raises money or at least you're you're not
raising money. Maybe maybe somehow it could end up working out,
but right now, your party's not raising money and that's a massive
concern going into the midterms.
for the day in Lucky Charms. Hey Porum. But you can do it if
it keeps you going and motivated to stick to the rest of your
diet because you get to enjoy that bowl of Lucky Charms in the
morning, you could totally do it. And then there'll be people
out there who are screaming at you for eating Lucky Charms. You're
like, "Ah, but I'm losing weight and I feel better and I'm healthy.
Leave me
So same thing with Ken Martin. He's winning. He's doing very
well. I have nobody I can't imagine anybody has any complaints
about
the results.
uh released a statement about the autopsy in conjunction with
the report. I'll just read a bit of it. "When I received the
report late last year, it wasn't ready for primetime, not even
close. And because no source material was provided, fixing it
would have been starting over from the beginning. Every conversation,
every interview, every data set dot dot dot. I'm not proud of
this product. It does not meet my standards and it won't meet
your standards. I don't endorse what's in this report or what's
left out of it. I could not
also, now
when Ken Martin said, "We've got lessons we took away from this
report."
How is he not totally How is he not lost all credibility?
What he said to Jon Favreau was, "We took lessons away. We're
going to focus on those lessons." And then he says, "This report
is utter garbage, and there's nothing to take away from it, and
I stand behind none of it."
So, what the [__] What the lessons were you talking
about?
What the lies were you putting out
That's wild. That's wild. Now,
I think Ken Martin's got to go, but it it has to do a lot more
with the Matt Yglesias article that I read and the Pod Save criticisms
his his total lack of
failure to fundraise. That's why he's got to go. It's not even
the report. The report's bad,
but it's the failure to fundraise. He can't handle one or the
other. He can't have both. in good faith put the DNC stamp of
approval on it, but transparency is paramount, so today I'm releasing
the report as I received it in its entirety unedited unabridged
with annotations for claims that couldn't be verified. Um just
to give you guys a sense of the kind of errors we're talking
about. On page 18, the report talks about the 2022 Georgia Senate
election and refers to it as an attempt to quote push through
an unqualified candidate whose job would have been little more
than rubber stamping the president's agenda. The DNC affixed
a footnote to that passage saying quote "In 2022, Joe Biden was
>> Turn it Oh,
our eyes having a hard time pulling the broom out for this one.
That's not great, man. That is not good.
How dare you, Jon Favreau, with that Michael Strahan gap between
your two front teeth? HOW HOW YOU LAUGH at the DNC and Ken Martin?
How dare you? Um
It's a small detail there. Um so John, it it sounds like the
person who wrote the report screwed up and it was
>> Yeah, I know. I know.
That's bad though. That's really bad.
I'm still coming through this report. It's like 200 pages long.
What's your reaction to all this so far? So my first reaction
is like I want to be careful here because
I've always thought that
people who sort of admit mistakes and then say, "Okay, I'm sorry.
Full transparency." Like we want to incentivize that behavior
because we don't want people to think, "Why would I tell the
truth now and release what I promised I'd release because then
I'm just going to get even more It's going to be worse because
we've had the Like a nuanced take from Jon Favreau right now?
Oh my god. >> conversations being in politics. And so like
Ken Martin gets credit, I think, for doing that. Like it is belated,
but he he he put it out. He apologized. So that is good. On the
other hand, the more I like read his statement and read his Substack
and then looked at the report like, you know, he he lied. Like
he's just he was they he promised a report. Oh my god.
Why? What good comes out of this?
Pointing out the lies to Jon Favreau? That Jon Favreau is upset
that that this guy straight-up lied to him?
What? Because he probably feels personally offended.
That he was obviously he was like basically pointing out the
problems and this guy was lying directly to his face. What good
comes out of telling your audience
that Ken Martin, the head of the DNC, lied?
Um holding somebody accountable for lying? What is the value
in that? That that's my question. What what What does that lead
to?
What does that lead to? Could he have not changed his mind? What
do you mean he lied? When you say he lied, that means he purposefully
misled, that He did purposefully mislead.
Because he quite literally lied. He lied.
When he said, "We have key lessons we're taking away from this
report." And then he releases the report and says it's totally
incompetent and we don't about anything in here. That is a lie.
He knowingly and intentionally lied.
Jesus, man. >> He never was going to do what he said he
was going to do. You have no evidence of that. Ken Martin may
have had every intention of releasing this report when he said
he was going to during the campaigning. And then when he saw
it, he said, "This thing is a disaster. I'm going to have to
go back on my word and people are going to be mad, but this is
just garbage that's going to hurt us and I have a duty first
and foremost to not do anything that hurts our party."
Things change. Biden said he would not pardon his son. Did Biden
lie? Does anyone out there think Biden was lying when he said
he would not pardon Hunter Biden? I don't think so. I think he
was convinced that Kamala was That's insanely different. It's
obviously different. That is changing your mind. He didn't say
He didn't say, "Oh, what would have What a What would have been
a good thing there? Or what's a comparison?" It's not the same.
I don't think Biden lied, actually. I think he had no intention
of I think he went in blind and had every intention of of like
his son getting through the legal system, the legal process,
like directly.
If he Oh, how do I put this? I think he just he didn't think
about it. I It feels different to me, right? It's different than
knowing that you have an incompetent report and saying, "Well,
we have lessons we're taking away. The report was fine, but I
and I'm delivering the information from the report that you need."
That's a lie covering up a mistake.
That would be like if Biden ran for president and and Hunter
already been convicted and he said he wouldn't pardon
That's that's like the difference, right? Cuz I think Joe knew
that Hunter might like get off of that. You know what I mean?
He he knew that Hunter might be found innocent or could just
get the charges dropped.
And so I and I think he felt that Hunter had done nothing wrong
and that would
It's like a different thing when he is faced with reality of
his son going to jail or possibly going to jail and he can stop
it, he feels like he has to do something. I do think it's different.
Martin is like
he is just lying to cover his ass. It's way different. was going
to win and he wouldn't have to. And then when Trump won, he realized
I've got to pardon Hunter. He's going to get bankrupted by this
DOJ. Either way you slice it, Ken Martin still lied, okay? Either
way you slice it, Ken Martin still lied. So, I don't think this
analogy works. Ken Martin's not that kind of liar anyway. Ken
Martin is not the sort of like, "Okay, I could understand why
you would lie here or why I could I could forgive you for lying
here." Ken Martin just lied to cover his ass.
It's way different. >> Jay attacking him and so I'm going
to have to change I'm going to have to go back on my word and
say and do something that I said I wasn't going to do. But does
anyone think he lied that Biden was like, "I never planned on
doing I'm always going to knew I was going to pardon him, but
I just told the American people I'm not going to." So, I don't
think Ken Martin lied to the Democrats to get elected that he
was going to release the report. I I'm I'm going to give him
the benefit of the doubt and assume that he genuinely wanted
to release the report thinking it would be a good thing and then
when he saw it, he said, "Oh, hell no."
He put his incompetent friend in charge of it. The incompetent
friend created an incoherent product. Then Ken announced that
they weren't going to release the
for reasons that had nothing to do with the truth about why they
weren't releasing it.
Well, again,
these are a lot of assumptions here and they're assuming the
worst in Ken Martin, too.
And I agree with you guys saying who cares about this? Why does
it matter? I'm with you. But these guys have It does matter that
he went on this that he went on a major podcast like this and
he lied openly. It totally destroys his credibility.
And by the way, all of this is a is a trap of his own making.
He didn't have to lie. He could have gone on there and said,
"Well, I don't really like the report or I don't think, you know,
we went in a different direction away from the report. We didn't
think the report was good quality." He could have just said something
like this, right? All he had to say was, "The report was poor
quality. We aren't going to release it." And then they could
have had a fight. But he said
"The report, it's got tons of work in it. They did a ton of work
on it, okay? And we got really important lessons that we are
messaging out to everybody
from that report."
That is just an overt lie.
He did it to himself. have dedicated their lives to calling Yeah,
we're we're we're giving like a action items to all everybody
in the party. We're letting everybody know about this. We're
giving them all the lessons.
Brother, what?
Lie after lie after lie after lie. >> Martin for not releasing
this report, completely ignoring the million of special elections
that the Democrats have won and the kicking of ass that the Democrats
are doing, right? That that all gets thrown to the side. Instead,
we're going to hyper fixate on this report that means nothing,
will change nothing, and obviously has had no impact on the stellar
results from this DNC chair. I could not ask for better results
from the Democrats right now. And yet these guys want to sit
here and cry about this innocuous thing that means nothing. Nothing
at all. It's the results that matter. The results.
Then, when anyone asked about it, including me, he decided to
not just lie, but gaslight people into being like, "You're the
problem." The You know, it's a Why don't you >> You are
the problem. When you're crying about something that doesn't
matter, and you're not deferring to the guy in charge who had
a change of heart for whatever reason,
then you are the problem. If you want to run the DNC, you go
run the DNC. But, I think Jon Favreau would take over as DNC
chair if he could.
I think he wants anybody who's not incompetent there. To sit
here and tell him that he's wrong and you're right when you're
not in that job and he's
you're useless. What are you doing?
If the Democrats were losing right now, you shouldn't just get
rid of the DNC chair. You should like actually You should actually
put them in a guillotine or something, okay? Not Obviously, that's
not the situation, but if you're losing to this trumpet man,
all right? If the DNC were losing special elections to this trumpet
man, holy man.
That would be a disaster.
Winning right now is almost is indicative of almost nothing.
You are not running good campaigns. Or Sorry, it doesn't mean
you're running good campaigns. It means almost nothing.
Ken could have released the exact statement along why he wasn't
going to release it. It would have been way >> I agree.
I think there's plenty of things Ken Martin could have done that
would have made this better. But, in the end, none of it matters
because we're winning. Why does any of this matter? There's no
evidence that he lied.
There's no evidence that he lied.
Ira, I just didn't watch the first interview or something.
Like I guess he just didn't watch the first interview. This is
insane. I What is Hiral talking about? He didn't lie.
Dude, do I have to pull Hold on. Let's go find this real quick.
Your exact quote was, "Of course it will be released." Why did
you change your mind on that? >> Well, look. I mean, what
I said all along, even when I ran for this position, is that
we were going to focus on the things that will help us win the
upcoming election. Uh example of some of the lessons, we've been
releasing them with um our donors and with activists and party
leaders. Man, this sounds so tricky going back and looking at
this. Cuz like by the letter of the law,
I don't think he's actually quite lying.
I think he's making it very different that he's learned lessons
from the 2024 election, and there was a report.
He's not necessarily saying he learned lessons from the report,
from the autopsy. He's saying they learned lessons from 2024,
and they're going to focus on the right things, which are the
lessons. Dude, it's crazy.
Do these people ever talk about intraparty power politics? If
they don't, who does? It seems like it's literally just sportsball,
team sports for these guys. Oh, like they should be. Well, that's
the issue is they're all focused on Well, at least Destiny and
some of the people around us here focused on like Hasan and what
that means. This is intraparty politics. This is
like more Biden-ali- Biden-aligned policy, or sorry, more Biden-aligned
populist types within the DNC sort of going to war with some
of the more corporate donor heavy, like the people who are in
with corporate donors, like the guys who run this podcast, the
Pod Save America podcast. These guys talk to big money donors.
And these guys think the big These guys have been saying the
big money donors don't have faith in the DNC right now because
it's all
And so they've been pressuring this guy to come out and release
this autopsy from 2024. That's what's happening. It is an intraparty
fight.
But they don't even get All of the people commenting on this
aren't even getting the good storylines cuz they all have a different
agenda they're pushing.
Like I covered this, and it was an awesome story. It was like
really cool cuz the information's like it's not even like public
or
it's like public in a way where you see these people fighting
back and forth but through proxies, right? And all you have to
do is like find a couple of the storylines and it makes
But none of the people who cover this in the liberal sphere at
least are covering it correctly. It's actually really disappointing
to me.
Anyway, yeah. So we've been talking about what those lessons
are and we've actually been putting those lessons into action.
And so it's not completely accurate to say that we didn't release
that child. Where we're keeping our focus is on the lessons that
can actually help us with Oh,
so it's not completely accurate. Oh, that's bad. That's bad right
there. Cuz he's implying the lessons aren't derived from the
report.
Oh, who are there Yeah, the the guy who's doing the the heated
interview here. This guy is not really aligned to somebody in
the party. He's more of a populist type.
But and he's like pushing a lot of money down into the states
and he's spending a bunch of the money they're raising on states
and getting like state parties
But before the election like early on. But the issue is he's
spending all of the money they're raising. Usually what you do
is you raise like a money and you save it all in your war chest
and then you get to about six 4 to 6 weeks out from the election
and you spend spend spend spend spend. Maybe even out to 8 weeks.
Spend spend spend spend spend.
All your ads, all of your everything,
And he's he's spending all their money now so they don't even
have a war chest that's building up and there's a bunch of people
who feel a a lot of anxiety going into the midterms because of
this.
Yeah, the the big money donor types want this guy out. He's like
he's not even like taking meetings with them. He's basically
saying if you guys don't trust us then you.
And so this is like pressure from big big money interests to
get this guy out cuz he's like kind of he's kind of I don't know
if it's like incompetence and ego mixed together or what it is,
but
This guy's a faucet and the donors are wary cuz he sucks. Yeah,
yeah, the DNC chair should be somebody who's talking to all the
big donors and he's more like small money donors, right? Like
lots of small money donors, more populist focused, getting more
more more like small money donors in.
And it's funny cuz a lot of the a lot of people are aligning
this guy with like the establishment DNC and John John Favreau
with like the populist Bernie Sanders leftist type people. And
that couldn't be further from the truth. Favreau was in the Obama
administration.
This guy is more of a populist. He like ran the Minnesota Farmers
Party or
There's like some
Democrat adjacent party in Minnesota that's like the the Minnesota
Farmers Party or some [__] right? I don't even know
I don't know what the [__] it is. I I don't I can't
remember the name. But people who can't follow politics or don't
understand or or just don't care are saying because John Favreau
gave a nice interview to Cenk Uygur and a mean interview to this
guy, that means he's like a leftist or that he's like trying
to help leftist or trying to help leftist accomplish their goals.
That couldn't be further from the truth.
It's just very silly lazy analysis.
Anyway, we can move >> Again, I'm leaning on the word lie
because lie means you purposefully So, we just caught the lie,
right? It would be weird to say we didn't release the report
cuz we're releasing lessons from the report. Then it comes out
that the report is total incompetence. It's totally like it's
totally
They're not taking anything from this report. They In fact, they
explicitly disavow the report. Yeah, now I can say he's lied.
He obviously lied. Come on. I do not believe he did that. Yet,
these guys do because they don't like him for whatever reason
or they're just Democratic Party haters. I don't know. I have
no idea.
But I do not assume that the chair of the DNC is lying to us.
who want to win. Why are you looking at the look in the past?
And then there's like an internal revolt at the DNC and among
donors and DNC members. And so then they release this. Like it's
just
He says in his Substack, this is one of the lessons that he >> Like
Like we see this, right? We see
It's a
He cares about the donors. He cares about the big money interests.
He does not give a [__] about socialists.
He says it explicitly. >> internal revolt at the DNC and
among donors and DNC members. And so then they released this.
Like it's just not
He says in his Substack, this is one of the lessons that he has
learned that he puts in the Substack piece about this about the
autopsy today. The Democratic brand is in trouble and needs repair.
We have to restore confidence in our party and show we can really
deliver on our campaign promises to the
That's the 2024
THAT WAS THE LESSON for 2024.
American people. [laughter] People need to be able to trust the
Democratic Party again. Trust is critical.
So I Wow, John is steaming. You're so cringe, John.
He said TRUST IS CRITICAL.
>> IT'S SO WEIRD.
Like it's so weird when I actually look into politics stuff and
I spend 5 minutes looking and you just see people
embarrassing themselves over and over again.
So man.
Wow, it's going to take a lot of work for Ken Martin to regain
my trust.
I am I am really steaming about this one. I don't know. It's
I am very skeptical of Ken going forward.
I think Favreau is of the same mind that Obama is. They don't
want
Like if you ever You guys have heard this that liberalism basically
like co-opts whatever ideas are good, right? Whatever ideas are
popular like eventually sort of co-opts them and and subsumes
them. I think that's what they're trying to do. I think that's
what Favreau is trying to do. I think that's what Obama was trying
to do when he went and hung out with a Zoran? Right? They're
trying to get a lot of these like more lefty types who are very
to they they want to shift more economic populist, but they want
to do so by co-opting. They want to bring these people in, right?
They want to subsume them into the party.
That's That's what they want to do. So, it's like I don't think
it's like a legitimate interest of oh, we really want to shift
lefty. I think it's like, "Okay, we need to we need to do
And okay, we'll reach out to these people. We'll be nice to them
and we'll we'll bring them in and maybe we'll throw them a bone
every once in a
>> He's going to have to work very hard to regain my trust.
Who gives a [__] about your trust? He's winning,
dude.
Like I don't know what he's doing, but I want more of it. And
so, if you think he's lying about the report, then he should
lie about a lot of other things because it we're winning. Whatever
he's doing is working, and I am happy to get behind it. I have
no arguments, no criticism.
The lack of self-awareness is insane. His entire job is to make
the party look good as if there's presumably as is theirs presumably,
but all they do is [__] on him. No, we Whoa. Whoa.
You know what the best way to look good is? It's to be good.
That's the best Bro, this is I If you ever go look at Dude, I
If you ever go look at like, you know, life coach life advice
stuff from like the mid 2010s,
like people will tell you like if you look for like style advice,
okay? People will tell you, you know what the best style advice
is? Hit the gym.
Cuz if you're fat, it doesn't matter if you're like tubby or
fat, it doesn't matter what shirt you wear. It's not going to
look good. The best way to look good is to be in shape. Right?
That's what the DNC needs. It's like I I I just wants a moo moo
to throw over this 700-lb DNC. It's like how about you hit the
gym so you can wear a T-shirt and look fine?
What is this? Stop putting Stop trying to put lipstick on this
pig.
We need whip this party into shape, man. It's time for a Rocky
training montage for the DNC. We have this weird thing on the
left where we think if we're criticizing we're helping.
I don't know when we came to that
I I I think it's okay to have some criticisms here and there.
It's healthy. But, boy, that's all we do on the left. When When
is the last time you heard anyone praising Ken Martin? I I don't
know if I've ever heard anyone say something nice about Ken Martin.
And yet, the guy's got Democrats winning in places we haven't
won in decades.
He's got turnout similar to midterms in special elections. He
He's got the electorate moved 13 points to the left on average
and just dominating. And people will just completely ignore that
he's the DNC chair and has anything to do with any of that. They
won't even look into any of his moves that he's made, anything
he's done, nothing. They'll just say he hid the report. >> Who thinks
Ken Martin is the reason we're winning special elections? Well,
it's not even that. It's It's like not the DNC either right now.
It's not like the DNC strategy, I don't think. It Ken Martin
doesn't even have like the the dumbest strategy for what he wants
to do. I just think he can't run the strategy he wants to run,
which is spending more money further up from elections in every
state, right? You can't do that without also being an ace fundraiser,
and he sucks at fundraising. And not in the literal sense that
would be good for fundraising, in a metaphorical sense. In a
metaphorical sense, he sucks at
similar to midterms in special elections. He He's got the electorate
moved 13 points to the left on average and just dominating. And
people will just completely ignore that he's the DNC chair and
has anything to do with any of that. They won't even look into
any of his moves that he's made, anything he's done, nothing.
They'll just say he hid I know what his moves are. I know that
he's trying to spend money in states and everywhere, even in
states that don't have electoral seats or not electoral seats
in America, but um
Well, like Guam, Puerto Rico, American Samoa. He's even spending
money in the DNC in those places, right? I know what his policies
are. I know he's trying to push money down to make it more distributed.
I know that.
My issue is the lack of fundraising
I think there is something to the fact that he raised the most
in the first year for a new DNC chair, I still think the fundraising
has been very low given the threat Maga poses and he's spending
so much money. Could be good. But you got to save something in
the war chest, man. You got to do something with it, right? You
got to save something for right before the election to buy ads.
Can't totally eschew conventional wisdom. report. Well, maybe
he should hide a lot more reports then because whatever he's
doing's working, man. Maybe he should hide some more stuff cuz
it's working.
I support it.
I contend that it's fine to call out lies. And he gets paid so
much to just be like, "Pay no attention to the lies, guys. The
lies don't care about the lies. Just let yourself get lied to."
Al Braw is such a
is such has been grifter. All he cares about is numbers.
And I I don't know, but I don't know about you guys, but the
results matter a whole lot more than
actions or things he said, man. Like none of that matters to
me at all. The results mean everything.
Do you think Do you think we've resolved that? Do we resolve
it? >> know. I mean, so look, I'm with you like I I'm glad
they put it out. I appreciate that they did this. It took way
too long, but whatever, we're here. Um I just big picture, I
don't think Ken Martin is the right person to be leading the
DNC right now.
NO. [screaming]
NO.
NO. NO.
No way. No way. No way. No.
Bad. You step down, [__] You step down, random podcast
dude. You.
we're winning by double digits.
It's time Can Martin step down.
It's time. He needs to do the right thing and get the hell out
of there, and we need chaos at the top of the DNC right now,
5 months before the midterms. Yes.
I mean, if that's if you get commitments for donors, I that might
be what you need, unironically. This is This is the
slug.
You step down from your dumb podcast, you ass.
hole.
I don't even hate IRI, by the way. This is I like I don't hate
IRI. It's It's honestly just funny to me watch him talk. You
are pathetic. >> Results don't matter. Not when there's
dark money and no perfect messaging. Kappa. Exactly.
Dude, these people are lost.
These people are so dude.
Results don't matter. Brother, you only have Trump here right
now. You only have Trump.
If If you That's your only thing, Trump is bad. That's all of
it. I don't care about your message right now. I care about the
fact that you guys aren't fundraising. I care about the fact
that you guys have showed The guy at the top of the DNC has shown
himself to be
If they want to try to hold it together through midterms, like
maybe you do But my god, if if donors are holding back their
money, like because they're just scared of this guy, they think
this guy is incompetent, he's just going to waste it. Like I
You're going to [__] yourselves. You're You have
a chance for like a major landslide here and you don't want to
let it slip away. You Ken Martin for not being absolutely perfect
and winning by triple digits and everything. Like dude, in what
world should Ken Martin step
Literally can't win by triple digits triple digits. Come on,
man. What? Winning by triple digits?
Putin don't win by triple digits, man. What are we talking about?
In what world?
I wish I could use harsher language, but I've committed myself
to not saying certain words, but I would call these people all
the words, man. I I hate these people. Everything about them
pisses me off. Can you imagine? It's like some beautiful girl
wants to sleep with you and she's naked in your bed and you're
like, "Not like this." And you're like, "What do you mean? I'm
here to sleep with you." You don't mean it like, "You! I'm out
of here."
We need the true tyrant to step down, the DNC.
>> I love it. And and do what? Replace Ken with what? That's
my question. What And what What will replace Ken? Someone who
will win by even more I mean, I've heard Wasserman Schultz like
literally filled the coffers massively.
To be honest, I know lefties would really hate that, but ultimately
you need money right now. I don't know I don't know what she
does now, but I heard she was really really good at >> Or
who regains your trust? Like it's so dumb, man. The whole thing
is so dumb. Fair enough. >> But here's the thing, they
would have found something else to attack him on. Just like trans
people in bathrooms and women's sports, if you eliminate that,
they'll find something else to attack trans people on because
it's not about the specific thing. They just latched onto this
to try to attack him. They don't care. They'll find something
else now that the report's out.
There's also the fundraising problem that you guys discussed
in the interview. There's some numbers out this week. The DNC
has 14.4 million on hand. The RNC has 123.9
million on hand. >> And we're winning by A MILE. SO
>> DUDE, THIS GUY IS OUT OF HIS MIND.
That it That That is He's out of his mind. He's out of his mind.
What is wrong with this guy? >> Well, maybe we're doing
something right. Maybe that's the right move. The The Republicans
are losing and the
Okay, hypothetically,
shouldn't this be incredibly worrying? You are spending way more
money than the RNC and you're winning in Yes, some special elections
right now. You're blowing out special
but you're not saving any money.
So, you're blowing out special elections special elections,
but you're not saving money and like isn't that going to possibly
look really really bad?
Like if you guys get to the midterms and you can't buy ads at
the same rate as the Republicans and it cuts those numbers massively,
wouldn't you say that's a terrible
And isn't that a real concern? >> The Democrats are overwhelmingly
winning. And yet you're going to crit Like of course you're the
only one spending significant money right now. Of course you're
winning. >> Besides the fundraising, it's working. Whatever
he's doing is working. So, maybe maybe give him an around IRA
is like watching a marathon runner sprint the first like 500
m of the race, right? Just sprint full out sprint for 500 m.
And he's like, "Dude, we're winning. We're What ARE WHY ARE YOU
MAD AT HIM? WHY ARE YOU GUYS SAYING HE'S DOING BAD?
We're winning. He's winning. He's way ahead." And it's like,
"Dude, you got You got a lot more distance to go, man."
And he like
Everybody can see that this is not a good strategy. Everybody
knows that you try to be efficient and not sprint, but they're
sprinting and sprinting and sprinting, it's sprinting.
Dude, that's what it feels like to me,
But I I like he has to be smart enough to see that, right? That
that's the argument. That the the Dems are sprinting in terms
of their spend right And it's just an uncertainty whether or
not they can win. And if they were fundraising massively, then
you wouldn't be that upset about it. But they're not fundraising
massively.